so this is what i mean by a power of a
power okay you've got a power and it's
being raised to another power
an exponent outside an exponent okay now
what does this equal to um how would we
write this
in factor form because this is an index
form at the moment right
well cubed means
do it do it three times right whatever's
in there
do it three times yeah are you going to
tell me nancy are you going to tell me
i was going to do an answer okay let's
get there first let's get there first
okay
so in in factor form it should be that
times that times that see three times
it's been cubed
does that make sense but our like one of
our first
index laws was when you multiply numbers
with the same base what did you do to
the indices
you add them exactly right so this
should be 2
plus 2 plus 2.
so that's 7 about 6.
so hold on a second have a look where
did that six come from that's not a
coincidence isn't it
yeah yeah good you can see what's going
on in here
can't you now hold on i'm not content
that could just be a coincidence let's
just try another one and see what
happens
let's try or i don't know let's go three
to the power of
five squared okay different numbers now
let's see what happens what does it mean
when you square it
yeah i already know the answer okay
let's get there first
okay that's right to square something
you multiply it by itself right so 3 to
the power of 5
times 3 to the power of 5 right
but just like before when you're
multiplying numbers
numbers with the same base so what i do
to the indices
you else i add them
adding is a better word than plusing
it's it's addition
not plus session okay so i add them
which is 3 to the power of 10. there's
the pattern again
it's still there isn't it right 2 times
3 is 6.
five times two is ten okay so what we're
going to do now is take it from concrete
examples
right and we want to turn this into a
law
we want to generalize this okay so
let me get rid of this
okay what if i don't know what the
numbers are
what if i say a to the power of m
whatever those are
okay to the power of n power of power
what would you write a to the pound
what did we do to get from here to here
i i multiplied did not think i heard it
right it's m
times n right or if you like
okay there you go does that make sense
so there you go now
just flowing right on from this okay you
can think about what happens if
so so put a box around that that's
important
okay what if i have two numbers in there
right
something like this a and b
who would that be equal to a a must
now again let's try it like i did over
here let's try it with some actual
numbers
and let's see if it lines up with lucas
and you give me the uh the actual law in
a second if we get it right okay
so example let's go two times three to
the power of five
okay two terms to the power of five what
does the five mean
it means do it five times right so i've
got
two times three times two times three
times two times i gotta do it five times
right okay hold on there's the fourth
one
and there is the fifth one okay
excellent but i can rearrange this it
doesn't matter what order you multiply
things in right how many twos do i have
i've got five of them so that's two to
the power of five how many threes do i
have
also five
okay so therefore what can i say over
here
look the two gets a five on it and a
three gets a five minute luke is your
truck
oh you can you can take half each you
did the first part then and then times
the um good well done all right
and in exactly the same way i won't
prove it this time but if i was dividing
instead of multiplying
like this okay each one is going to get
its power
like this okay
there you go